le meilleur sur le sahara et interviews
du monde interview guimond joeystarr
c'est quoi votre fleur préférée message
pour vous joeystarr c'est quoi la soirée
idéale à 2 à 15 pages ce la plus
romantique que vous ayez fait dans votre
vie bas contrairement à ce que tout le
monde croit genscher possible donc j'en
fais plein ouais ouais mais souvent le
croisais qu'un petit bouquet de fleurs
ou bien je ne connais pas mais qui
connaissait bien sûr je me tiens dans la
bouche en plus c'est quand la dernière
fois qu'une femme vous a blessé de jouer
enfin sens figuré bien sûr quand on a
porté plainte
c'est vexant
sa tenue de questions dures et ses
interviews mauvais on se fait un bisou
girouard je leur était pour moi si tu
deviens tactile en plus j'ai risqué
bagne pour l'avouer bien séché venir à
la télé là un grave tu as l'impression
de faire un film
j'ai compris que après il aurait fallu
qu'ils ne vendent 1
il était 10 fois plus inquiet par sac
que pas refaire le film
c'est un truc c'est un exercice que
j'aime pas du tout je fais pas mal
pourtant commencé comme les autres donc
situer c'est sûr que ça fait le trou
c'est qu'ils les autres gynéco
non
cela ramène moi quand c'est joey starr
teint moi je suis comme tout le monde
j'ai très peur c'est clair il ya un truc
tous les deux non chantre autre hétéro
donc la part comme ça je passe bien quoi
inquiéter rondelle quand même bien aussi
ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire
un beau scandale stratégie arrête ouais
c'est ça ouais sa stratégie par le
scandale c'est plus on fait de bruit
plus on montre qu'on existe c'est un peu
comme les chiens courants puissants plus
dans les coins sauf que nous ces puits
puis sur les autres si un plein à ceux
qui nous ont mis en oeuvre sur plus
court ta [ __ ] et donc qui me faisait
peur non aujourd'hui ce dimanche donc ça
faisait peur tutoyer dedans